♪ ♪
>> Tucker: IN THE WAKE OF ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN'S RESIGNATION AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF NEW YORK,
SOME OF HIS LONG-TIME FRIENDS ON
THE LEFT ARE PROFESSING SHOCK.
YOU HEARD THEM.
WE JUST CAN'T BELIEVE IT, THEY
SAY.
HOW CAN A MAN SO PUBLICLY
COMMITTED TO FEMINISM BEAT
WOMEN?
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
BUT OF COURSE IT MAKES PERFECT
SENSE.
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS IS ALWAYS A
MARKER FOR SECRET CREEPINESS.
THE PEOPLE YELLING THE LOUDEST
ARE USUALLY HIDING THE MOST.
KEEP THAT IN MIND THE NEXT TIME
YOU'RE SOME DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIAN LECTURING YOU ABOUT
YOUR MORAL INFERIORITY.
THAT'S THE GUY YOU NEED TO WATCH
CAREFULLY.
CHANCES ARE HE'S UP TO SOMETHING
AWFUL BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
HYPOCRISY ISN'T JUST A FEATURE
OF MODERN LIBERALISM, IF THE
HEART OF MODERN LIBERALISM.
EVER WONDER HOW PEOPLE WHO
ADVOCATE FOR ABORTION CAN SAY
THEY STAND FOR CHILDREN?
A MOVEMENT THAT DEMONIZES AN
ENTIRE RACE CAN CLAIM TO OPPOSE
RACISM?
AL GORE CAN TRAVEL BY PRIVATE
JET WHILE TRYING TO BAN YOUR
SUV.
BECAUSE CONSISTENCY DOES NOT
MATTER TO THE LEFT, ONLY VIRTUE
MATTERS.
WE ARE GOOD PEOPLE, THEREFORE WE
MUST RULE.
YOU ARE NOT, THEREFORE YOU MUST
OBEY.
AL GORE DOESN'T BELIEVE HE'S A
HYPOCRITE.
ERIC SCHNEIDERMAN PROBABLY
DOESN'T THINK HE IS EITHER.
YOU CAN'T COMMIT SIN IF YOUR
INTENTIONS ARE PURE AND LIBERALS
THINK THEIR INTENTIONS ARE THE
PUREST.
IF THAT SOUNDS LIKE THEOLOGY AND
NOT PUBLIC POLICY, IT'S BECAUSE
IT IS THEOLOGY.
MODERN LIBERALISM IS A
REPLACEMENT FOR THE PROTESTANT
CHRISTIANITY THE LEFT WORKED SO
HARD TO UNDERMINE AND DESTROY.
THEY ARE SPEAKING THE LINKAGE OF
FAITH, ALBEIT A FAITH WITHOUT
GOD.
THIS IS THE MAIN REASON THE
RIGHT AND LEFT TALK PAST EACH
OTHER, THE REASON OUR PUBLIC
DEBATES ARE SO WEIRD AND
UNSATISFYING.
ONE SIDE ARRIVES WITH STATS AND
FACTS AND ARGUMENTS AND THE
OTHER GRABS ABOUT ITS DECENCY.
ONE IS TRYING TO CONVINCE, THE
OTHER SIDE IS TRYING TO CONVERT.
YOU CAN BE THE LIBERAL IN AN
ARGUMENT, BUT YOU CAN EVER
CONVINCE THEM THEN YOU WON.
HE CARES MUCH MORE DEEPLY THAN
YOU AND THEREFORE KNOWS HE'S
RIGHT.
NOTHING CAN CONVINCE THEM
OTHERWISE.
SOMEWHERE TONIGHT ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN IS MARINATING IN
HIS SHAME, PROBABLY UNSHAVEN AND
ALONE.
HIS CAREER IS OVER, HE FACES
YEARS OF POTENTIAL LEGAL ACTION.
HE IS A BROKEN MAN, HE IS IN
AGONY AND GET ON SOME LEVELS
DESPITE ALL OF THAT ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN STILL KNOWS HE'S A
BETTER PERSON THAN YOU ARE.
SET PARENT PREDICTED IN PUBLIC
ON TWITTER THAT SCHNEIDERMAN
WOULD BE EXPOSED AS A CREEP AND
HE SAID IT LAST NOVEMBER.
YESTERDAY HE TWEETED THIS.
HOW DID I KNOW THIS AND
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR BILL
DE BLASIO KNEW THIS?
GREAT QUESTION.
SETH JOINS US TONIGHT.
THAT WAS A REMARKABLY PRESCIENT
PRESCIENT PRESCIENT TWEET.
>> TO ME IT WAS JUST KIND OF --
I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST AN OPEN
SECRET.
I HAD HEARD STORIES AND RUMORS
ABOUT SCHNEIDERMAN FOR YEARS.
I'D BEEN TOLD BY AT LEAST THREE
OR FOUR DIFFERENT PEOPLE SINCE
MAYBE 2009 THAT HE IS INTO ROUGH
SEX WITH WOMEN, THAT HE LIKES TO
DATE STAFFERS AND IS A LITTLE
PUSHY WITH THEM, THAT HE TRIED
TO KIDNAP A REPORTER AND
WOULDN'T LET HER OUT OF HIS CAR
TAKING HER TO HIS APARTMENT.
SO I SORT OF ASSUMED THAT THIS
WAS JUST COMMON KNOWLEDGE.
MORE OR LESS.
I'M NOT DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
ALBANY POLITICS OR NEW YORK CITY
DEMOCRATIC CIRCLES.
I'M AN EDITOR FOR A MODERATELY
CONSERVATIVE MAGAZINE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE NOT
EXACTLY IN THE LOOP AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF PROGRESSIVE
NEW YORK IS WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT'S WHY IT SEEMS STRANGE THAT
EVERYONE WAS SAYING THIS IS THE
CRAZIEST THING WE'VE EVER HEARD.
>> Tucker: IS CLEARLY NOT.
IF YOU RAISE A REALLY GOOD, I
THINK I'M A CENTRAL QUESTION,
WHICH IS IF YOU HEARD ABOUT IT,
IS IT PLAUSIBLE THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE, ONE OF
HIS CLOSEST ALLIES, PRESUMABLY
ONE OF HIS CLOSEST FRIENDS,
ANDREW CUOMO, HAD NEVER HEARD OF
IT?
>> IT SEEMS IMPLAUSIBLE TO ME.
IMPLAUSIBLE TO ME THAT ANY
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
NEW YORK STATE HADN'T HEARD IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I CAN SAY.
ANDREW CUOMO HAS BEEN STEEPED IN
NEW YORK STATE POLITICS FOR 40
YEARS.
HE BASICALLY HAS A PRIVATE ARMY.
HE KEEPS TABS ON EVERYTHING AND
EVERYONE.
HE'S EXTRAORDINARILY PARANOID.
>> Tucker: I KNOW.
>> SO I WOULD IMAGINE THAT HE
WOULD KNOW EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYONE IS UP TO AT ALL TIMES.
>> Tucker: HE'S A THOROUGHLY
BIZARRE PERSON.
I'VE DEALT WITH HIM.
THAT'S EXACTLY THE WORD THAT
COMES TO MIND AND I DON'T USE IT
LIGHTLY, HE'S PARANOID.
THIS IS STRANGE BECAUSE
SCHNEIDERMAN WAS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
IT WASN'T JUST SOME FUNCTIONARY.
HE JUST WASN'T THE NIGHT CITY
EDITOR OF THE DAILY NEWS.
THE CHEESE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OF THE STATE.
THE SUGGESTION THAT HE KIDNAPPED
SOMEBODY, YOU WOULD THINK THAT
ONE OF HIS PEERS WOULD FOLLOW UP
ON IT.
>> YOU MIGHT THINK SO.
AT THE SAME TIME, NEW YORK STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS UNIQUE
POWERS AND IS AN IMMENSELY
POWERFUL FIGURE.
I DON'T THINK ANY
ATTORNEY GENERAL -- ANY STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAS THE KIND OF POWER
THAT THE NEW YORK
ATTORNEY GENERAL DOES.
HOWEVER, IF YOU NOTICE, OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS IN NEW YORK STATE
AND NEW YORK CITY THERE HAS BEEN
A LOT OF CORRUPTION
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> BUT HE HAS NOT BEEN LEADING
THEM.
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN LARGELY DONE
BY THE FEDS.
THERE'S TRIALS GOING ON IN
ALBANY RIGHT NOW OVER -- SHELDON
SILVER IS GOING TO BE RETRIED.
A NUMBER OF ANDREW CUOMO'S
ASSOCIATES, JOE WAS JUST CONVICT
ASSOCIATES, JOE WAS JUST CONVICD
ASSOCIATES, JOE WAS JUST CONVIC.
THIS WAS FEDERAL ENDING
NEW YORK CITY, INVESTIGATIONS OF
BILL de BLASIO WERE LARGELY
BEING DONE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: KIND OF FUNNY.
MEANWHILE, THIS GUY IS SUING
EVERYBODY ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING.
>> GLOBAL WARMING OR COMING UP
WITH WAYS TO HAVE PART IN PROOF
INDICTMENTS OF TRUMP ASSOCIATES
OR SUING THE VITAMIN INDUSTRY.
>> Tucker: MEANWHILE, THE
CESSPOOL AROUND HIM GOES